[Music]
hello everyone Eddie Good Guys locksmith
here today we have a new programmer
that's called Ka
996 it's a new programmer that's
supposed to come out we got it from UHS
Hardware we're going to do a little test
see if we
can add a key to a Ford
Mustang push to start 2017 let's see how
it work emo North
America
Ford we are in
USA we're going to go scroll down to
Mustang
15 to
19 smart
key keyless
system smart key
programming the alarm is dis active I
got to say
and we will let you know as soon as we
get an answer after the wait time Keys
number changed to three we don't want
the next key we don't have one learning
is
complete we're going to go out from the
system
unplug let's take the remote test the
remote and let's start up the car
[Music]
car is on Ka a996